she's really weird look because he's
missing legs
we have deadlines we have other videos
that we got to work on sooner than later
and this video is already taken up more
time than typical video because it's
compassion project here's the original
footage camera doesn't move it's locked
off now I've got to overlay the clean
plate which is the background without
any people in it's putting a rough
Slanket over the body but now with his
hands and his belt is all fuzzy so from
there you now max back in his hands and
a more sharp mask around the belt
floating above the ground thanks to the
magic of movies this brings us to a
point where we can now drop in the
render oh now they're there the whole
process is called painting out when you
ever hear someone say I'm going to paint
that out that's what they mean they're
going to put the clean plate back on top
of that and make it so that it never
existed to begin with like polenta lower
half of his body here oh boy getting
getting this duck real thing to to work
and render and all that was a story all
on his own I've got a few people help me
today one of which was Gabe who was
pretty solid at After Effects and has
helped me but we also have a surprise
guest today Jordan came out surprised
Gabe now Jordan mr. rad rash himself was
in town hey can I like help with
something I was like yes I need your
help right now this is all true we're
using Niko's car and he requested that
we replace his license like this is the
perfect opportunity to throw in an
Easter egg from darkwing duck you
basically did everything I was going to
try to do here without any help or
assistance mocha I made a call to action
a couple weeks ago trying to ask for
help I've gotten like 160 emails from
people like offering their help so that
was extremely overwhelming choosing who
to work with stuff but this is a guy I'm
working with on the video it wasn't
expecting you to literally stop it there
only once best
never I'll never use any sort of like
transition because they usually just
kind of come across with pet there's a
classic movie called Ocean's eleven it's
really good about people putting out
fires in Brazil they walk into this
elevator here they're using this as a
classic scene transition the whole
reason why I wanted to talk about is
because I thought it was more
interesting than just a linear wipe to
either side well it turns out it's just
a linear wipe from either side what's
interesting is that is the wife isn't
with the doors I feel like that would be
the obvious first thing is that it would
go with the doors like as the doors are
closing the linear wife is with the door
is coming I feel like logically that
makes sense I don't know if creatively
that a good idea at all this is not
centered why is it all Genki only Luger
the line lock look is right over a Ruben
here yeah look
one of that's why I did it Snoopy blue
with blue food with a fan he's pointing
it right where they're going to be
sitting in the next scene
you've emitted it naturally with Drew
and there's a line of palm trees dead
center for factors to focus your
attention right there this is something
that you will probably not notice when
watching the movie but that's the point
you're not supposed to notice this thing
it's supposed to subtly influence how
you're absorbing the movie that's cool I
want to see more of that little another
the transition shot you put it up the
doors close excludes it okay and now we
flip the 180 what's between them all
you're right you're right so it's like
there's an interesting camera movement
in this scene you at the end of it
they're talking he's still talking
between them and then the camera does an
actual cushion as like you're crazy
who do you have in mind do they push it
right in and now it's exclusively him
oh they actually they finished that
scene with a normal linear white Peter
did you learn this in college oh you did
he's smarter than you good Carmichael
got to get back to doing some via text
or gizmo duck oh yeah I was I was at
somebody's house helping them in the
backyard and I said hold on give me an
hour and I went to my computer that I
had set up on a 800 by 600 monitor and I
decide you know just there's no pool
than that monitor lots of people have
sent me finished models of gives they
just went ahead and modeled it yours
looks pretty good but the problem was
that it wasn't like at all what I was
going for so just casual mentions like I
mean that's not really well known apart
for more like a militarized hit piece
but then like literally the next day you
sent me a refined version of what you
had done oh that was almost exactly what
I was looking for I send that to like a
half an hour later was it half an hour
yeah you would send me an email I would
give it on my phone I'd go to my
computer at work I'd send it to you
either a half an hour or an hour later
I'd wait a whole day pretty hurtful I
was really busy so yeah just come
walking through the rig and just go
ahead and like move things around what
an animated rig is is a controller that
allows you to move the 3d model and all
the connection for instance you can move
that top piece in the springs and all of
that will move accordingly it's not just
going to break and pull apart this is
all really cool and we'll set up the
problem is that I don't know how to use
my ax and we're eventually will figure
out how we will go about rendering me so
Peter I've been studying irritation are
you going to be in on the game of life
I don't understand it our enjoyment is
in what would the state can push up if
you say the word okay which was the
Secession battery can be sent out yep
the word could be said now the word is
mine and I and ate like mammal and if
you say the word and someone got you to
say strengthening the thing and you're
on a tent you get a push up there and
then this can happen pain now - the baby
dies and this is three to which they got
you safe little day if I am on top of it
and we're in a conversation you said of
your own court and I catch you got you
so your defense against that is pretty
much entire conversation and finally got
you to say it was a sale when we paint
work hey Jake Peters in Peters in here
in the game he doesn't know what he just
got himself into it has all of the
animations were done inside of Maya and
now really wanted to render the stuff on
this computer with octane we managed to
figure out a really good system just to
save it as a 3ds max file now I can
actually do all the rendering on this
puget computer with for 1080 video cards
in it
we were able to do this in
record-breaking time thanks to our team
of very talented artists and clones and
a very monster PC thanks to Puget for
making that PC for us I don't have to
say that about them I just love Puget
and they made an awesome computer so
that's the basic compositing workflow
I definitely oversimplified it maybe you
don't know how to do visual effects you
have no idea what I'm going to be
talking about so I want to show
something a little bit more approachable
you want to learn more about the
technical aspects of this we can
actually talk about this one-on-one if
you support us on patreon you know in
case you're curious
leave a comment in this one let me know
what you thought I believe if you
haven't seen yet what are you doing go
wash that giggle on that video
all people doers or I will deal justice